[Musique]
quand en commun ce merveilleux petit
gâteau c'est joli macarons et cet
alléchante tarte au citron de la
meringue deux ingrédients seulement
blanc d'oeuf et sucre mais trois façons
de faire à l'italienne en fait il faut
verser tout doucement si on verse trop
vite on risque de cuire les blancs
d'oeufs à la française
et à la Suisse il faut vraiment y aller
doucement et là la patience l'ingrédient
miracle pour les trois méthodes trois
techniques différentes trois apparences
différentes
c'est sûr que la meringue française
baille beaucoup plus légère beaucoup
plus aérienne parce qu'elle est montée à
froid la Suisse elle est beaucoup plus
dense brillante aussi à la minute où il
y a une cuisson à la base là c'est plus
brillant c'est plus lourd l'italienne
elle allait beaucoup plus solide elle va
gonfler plus les meringues ça fait
toujours un peu peur la majorité des
gens attendent meringue puis ils sont
comme moi Dieu qu'est-ce qui va arriver
fait que des petites spécificités là à
prendre en compte Isabelle soriol
enseigne la pâtisserie la meringue pour
elle ce n'est pas stressant premièrement
ça prend les bons ingrédients fait que
les blancs d'oeufs doivent être
impeccable aucune trace de jaunes d'oeuf
de dingue sont frais et le sucre il y a
aucune impureté dedans c'est du sucre
tout simplement
Isabelle nous livre ses secrets pour
réussir la meringue à la Suisse la plus
simple selon elle sa particularité le
bain-marie donc on va chauffer au même
arrêt les blancs d'oeuf et le sucre en
les chauffant ensemble le sucre va
fondre ce qu'il faut faire attention il
faut pas que ça bout
si ça vous le blanc va coaguler qu'on
veut pas ça on va chauffer à 50 60
degrés Celsius maximum donc je mets un
peu de citron dans le bol je suis un peu
on met le sucre et les blancs
jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas trop
compliqué c'est pas du tout compliqué
pourquoi le jus de citron
[Musique]
il y a de la matière grasse dans le fond
du bas ou et on va nettoyer on va
enlever avec le jus de citron puis ça va
aider à monter voilà merci à vous bonne
journée au revoir aux merveilleux de
Fred on fait de la meringue française la
meringue française c'est un tiers de
blanc d'oeuf de tiers de sucre et battu
au fruit et ensuite c'est cuit au four
ventilé c'est l'ingrédient de base pour
notre gâteau c'est notre spécialité le
merveilleux qui a un cœur de meringue
qu'on monte alors ensuite on la robe de
crème fouettée et on le roule ensuite
soit dans des copeaux de chocolat noir
ou blanc soit dans de la meringue
cristallisée qu'on cristallise
nous-mêmes on la vend également en me
renforsadée en petite rosace on sait pas
la même puissant là elle va être plus
dur donc elle va être cuite plus
longtemps et moins chaud
ici c'est la meringue italienne qui sert
à confectionner les bases et les
chapeaux de tous ces macarons on la cuit
avec un sucre liquide chaud
non italienne c'est une meringue à base
donc de blanc d'oeuf et de sucre cuit
donc on prend du sucre de l'eau on monte
à 118 degrés et on va verser ça sur des
blancs qui sont émulsionnés c'est quoi
le truc pour ne jamais la rater
si votre question si on n'a pas de
thermomètre à la maison on peut toujours
tremper une cuillère dans de l'eau
froide dans le sirop et à nouveau dans
l'eau froide et la petite boule de sucre
qu'on va réussir à en ressortir doit
former une petite boule quand même assez
dure mais qui garde encore un peu de
moelleux
alors la meringue italienne est utilisée
généralement pour des produits qui vont
avoir une plus ou moins longue
conservation on veut du moelleux mais on
veut de la tenue dans le temps
est-ce que les œufs doivent être
température pièces c'est sûr que si ils
sont tempérés ça va être mieux ça va
mieux monter à la main c'est une tâche
longue et ardue mais au batteur
électrique ou sur socle il faut aussi
mettre du temps si on l'enlève trop vite
ben ça va faire une meringue sympa
à ce stade là elle est très bonne mal
encore besoin peut-être de 5 10 minutes
de foisonnement
si on ne fait pas d'omelette sans casser
des œufs on ne fait pas de meringue non
plus mais que faire avec tous ces jaunes
abandonnés on s'inspire de ce qui a mené
à l'invention de la meringue au XVIème
siècle à l'époque bon nombre de
pâtisserie exigeaient seulement des
jaunes alors on a pensé à monter les
blancs en neige aujourd'hui encore on ne
veut rien gaspiller
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les jaunes
d'œufs des flancs des Natas tout ce qui
en fait va demander plus de jaune que de
blanc simplement
[Musique]
faut que ça se tienne mais faut pas que
ça soit trop ferme dans la meringue
italienne plusieurs utilisations et pour
le macaron ça prend une meringue qui est
quand même souple et brillante si elle
est brillante c'est à dire qu'elle est
réussie
[Musique]
donc ça prend quand même beaucoup de
précision même pour les habitués comme
vous là on fait pas ça à l’œil on peut
tout faire à l'oeil mais le résultat
sera pas intéressant c'est sûr qu'on
peut faire de la magie tout le temps
mais en pâtisserie tu peux pas tricher
vraiment pas un petit peu pas prendre de
raccourci tu peux pas
[Rires]